[Music]
this magical place is the most isolated place in the world
it is now one of the most
polluted places by micro plastics
[Music]
if I walk on this beach at home
a plastic bottle I want to have
the  need to see the need to feel the need
for English
[Music
] garbage arrived by
sea 95% of the garbage that arrives on
the coasts of its the product of industrial fishing
to see this garbage bothers me a lot
it's  there that I really
realized that something had to be
done
[Music]
sometimes I go three times a
week to clean the door and mind
but four times
there are places 2
that can clean in  half an hour
and places where you can spend three
hours
[Music] of
course we can do another
thing but I feel much more
useful doing this work
[Music]
to live here you have to give
something to the east
I have to
go to Lille c  e she gave me
[Music]
I'm talking about the new generation of the island
be aware
they live on a privileged place
I'm even sure that my dreams are
about to be contained
[Music]